Julia does not know how many men she has
had sex with she thinks it's been 10 12
or even more every night the 30 year old
Romanian has worked as a prostitute for
years selling her body in brothels bars
and on the street
Julia has no School Leaving Certificate
she bore her first child when she was
just 14 and then she had another one the
money she earned cleaning buildings in
Romania was not enough to survive she
went abroad and became a sex worker it
would be difficult but it was much worse
than I'd imagined the first three weeks
especially were extremely hard
everything that I had to go through but
I always thought about my children and I
told myself that I was there to help my
family and my children
she worked in Switzerland Greece and
France for the last five years she
worked in the southern German city of
Stuttgart at some point she could not
take it anymore
she wanted out she had her last customer
in March women like Julia can get help
at sister's Association a counseling
center for women who want to escape
prostitution located in the middle of
Stuttgart's red-light district the NGO
finds part-time jobs for women and gives
them financial support until they're
able to live independently it also
provides medical assistance and there's
always someone who will listen the
vendee follow all [ __ ] most if the
woman wants out and does not have a pimp
if she is not being held prisoner then
she can indeed leave a brothel but she
will not find a place to sleep she will
not find anyone who will give her food
she cannot just go to some Authority and
ask for accommodations or for welfare
she's not eligible for that and that's
what makes it so difficult for socially
that's not so the most she can get is a
ticket back to her home country the
combin con isn't ticket intimately
although Julia says she has never had a
pimp that would make her a rare
exception
she earned 30 euros per 20-minute
session with a customer it is I mostly
worked until 3 o'clock in the morning I
could not have stood it any longer but
there were also women there who endured
it all night they drank alcohol and took
drunks got high just to get through it
Julia says the pressure never let up she
had to earn up to 130 euros a day just
to pay for a room on top of that she
needed to earn money to send home she
was hardly able to save anything
she began having panic attacks and she
still suffers from them today in
hindsight I would not do it again I kept
thinking I have to look for something
else but I was not able to find any
other work force in Ferguson now Julia
once again works as a cleaner
she found the job with the help of
sisters and she's proud she enjoys the
sunshine and wearing normal clothes she
through her old ones away the ones she
would need here in Leonard's quarter
stood God's red-light district where the
streets are abandoned by day but the
bars and venues are full by night where
muscular men stand in doorways and
inside awaiting customers are women who
like Julia are mostly from Eastern
Europe no one knows exactly how many
there are
julia has left it behind her all she has
our old photos she does not want to show
except for this one with her mother she
likes it
not the ones in which she is obviously
dressed like a sex worker today Julia is
a different person